[MUSIC PLAYING]
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello.
I'm Dustin Kirkland, a
product manager at Google,
and your host at KubeCon
Copenhagen. I'm joined here
by one of my colleagues,
Matt Rickard,
who's a software engineer on
Google's container tools team.
Matt, tell us a little
bit about scaffold.
MATT RICKARD: Sure.
Skaffold is a developer
workflow tool made specifically
for Kubernetes.
It helps you get
started with Kubernetes.
It helps you develop
your apps on Kubernetes.
And it really targets that
inner development workflow
of build and deploy.
And it also utilizes
some of the other tools
that we've published on our
team, such as Kaniko, which
is are on-cluster build system.
So the idea is that you can
use Skaffold to not only build
and deploy, but with your
cluster as your only kind
of dependency.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Right.
And Skaffold interfaces
with other aspects
of Google Kubernetes or
Kubernetes in general?
MATT RICKARD: Yeah.
So the Kubernetes API is
exactly what we're targeting.
So with Skaffold, it's
pluggable in the sense
that you can build and
deploy in a variety of ways,
but your cluster is really
the only thing that you need.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: OK.
So a developer writing
some code on their MacBook,
walk us through, I
just wrote some Ruby
and I want to
deploy that to GKE.
MATT RICKARD: Sure.
So you write your code, you
write your Dockerfile, which
is your way to describe
your container image,
you write some
Kubernetes manifest,
which is how you're going
to describe your resources
on your Kubernetes cluster.
And then you write the
Skaffold yaml file,
which actually just
brings both of those
together and gives you the
full metadata from source
to deployment.
So Skaffold takes that Skaffold
yaml, it will build your image,
it will deploy it.
It will actually introspect your
image for all of your source
code dependencies and
perform a file watch on that,
so when those files
change, it kicks off
that rapid development
loop and you're
able to get that native
experience, but on a cluster.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And then
you're cooking with grease.
MATT RICKARD: Then you're
cooking with grease.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: All right.
I understand you
have a demo for us.
You want to walk us
through this demo?
MATT RICKARD: Sure.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: All
right, let's see it.
MATT RICKARD: Cool.
So here, I'm just in the Getting
Started portion of the Skaffold
repository.
You can check this out at
googlecontainertools/skaffold.
And what I have here is I have
a very basic go program here.
It's just going to print
"Hello world!" every second.
I have a Dockerfile
that describes it.
So here I'm using a
multistage Dockerfile.
You could really use any sort of
Dockerfile here that you want.
And then I have a very simple
Kubernetes resource definition
here, which is just
a pod that deploys
this Getting Started
container on my cluster.
If we look a little bit
at the Skaffold yaml,
you can see two main parts
to it, the first being build.
And we just have a
list of artifacts
here, the first being
our Skaffold example.
The really cool
thing about Skaffold
is that you can deploy multiple
images and multiple deployments
at the same time.
So the idea behind that is that
in this microservice world,
cloud-native world, your
services might be split up
into many different
microservices
and you'll need to be
developing on multiple
of those at the same time.
So Skaffold supports all
sorts of workflows like that.
And then the deploy stanza
here is basically just saying,
take all of my Kubernetes
manifests and deploy them.
And I'll just go ahead and
I'll do a Skaffold dev.
So this is just going to
do a build and deploy,
and then perform a watch on
the file system dependencies.
So you can see that
we're streaming
our logs from our
deployed artifacts here.
It's just saying, "Hello world!"
every second.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Now,
that deployed locally
or that deployed to the cloud?
MATT RICKARD: Yeah,
so good question.
So here I'm using
a Minikube cluster,
so it's local to my laptop.
But Skaffold works both
remotely and on local clusters.
And there are some
optimizations that we
make for the local
cases where we
don't have to push all
the artifacts around,
but the experience
is exactly the same.
So now I'm just going to go
and change some code here.
I'm going to say,
"Hello KubeCon!"
And then I just saved it.
And this will kick off the
build and deploy cycle again.
And you can see that we've
already redeployed our new pod,
and it's printing
out, "Hello KubeCon!"
So you get that really
fast inner development
loop for your workflow.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: That was
incredibly, incredibly fast.
MATT RICKARD: So of course,
this is a minimal example.
So we're only deploying
a very small go binary.
But in practice,
it is quite fast.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
And have you heard
from users using Skaffold
for much larger, maybe
real production-type workloads?
MATT RICKARD: Yeah, absolutely.
And in that case,
it's still great
for that inner development
loop, but we also
have a mode called Skaffold Run.
And so Skaffold Run
will just run this
build and deploy pipeline once.
So the idea is that
you can call this
from a product such as Google
Container Builder, or Jenkins,
or Spinnaker.
And then you can have the
same kind of CI/CD workflow
as you have locally.
So that bridges
the gap, and users
aren't left on this cliff
of having all of these tools
locally, and then having
to learn something
else in their CI/CD pipelines.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: That's superb.
[MUSIC PLAYING]